well thank you all for coming I know
that it's difficult to be inside
learning on a Sunday afternoon when it's
so nice and warm out but I appreciate
you coming to learn today to get started
on the github repo that is listed there
if you'd like there is a copy of the
slides and also an I Python notebook
that covers what we'll go over today on
getting started with hdf5 to begin I
want to get you thinking about whether
or not you're a scientist so a pion test
is a Python programming scientist I am a
scientist even if you're not a pion tist
maybe you're drowning in text files and
that happens to a lot of people dealing
with data and if you have lots of text
files you may find yourself frequently
grepping in order to find a particular
text file that you're interested in or
you might be extending filenames for
every processing step in your data
analysis routine which makes grepping
all that more fun or you're just looking
for something that is accessible
compressed and organized for your data
so these are all really good reasons to
use hdf5 they're all the reasons that I
use HDI v how many people in here have
used hdf5 before quite a few of you I
will let you know that I'm going to go
through H 5pi from a very beginner and
novice standpoint so hopefully you can
bring a lot of other people up to speed
but I'm happy to Scott to discuss more
advanced topics afterwards
Who am I well first and foremost I am a
computational neuroscientist I'm from
Minneapolis Minnesota which we have
redefined as the North where I go to
school at the University of Minnesota
and I'm working on my PhD in biomedical
informatics and computational biology
okay Vicki recently I left a position at
the brain Science Center which is
located at the Minneapolis VA and where
my research was focused on studying the
brain network in healthy humans I have
recently been offered a new post in an
exciting lab of dr. Sami Donny's Brain
Injury Research Lab which is at another
local hospital in
lists where I will be continuing my work
studying brain networks in patients with
brain trauma and that would be people
with TBI and and/or concussions that
said as a computational neuroscientist I
deal with a lot of data and lots of
different kinds of data so one of the
instruments we use is
magnetoencephalography or ma G and this
provides high temporal resolution brain
function information about brain
function from this instrument we acquire
time series that are on the order of
tens of hundreds of time points and then
for given for the instrument that we
were using there 248 sensors so this
would be for one scan so if we have one
one subject in a session we have quite a
bit of raw data that we're dealing with
and in different kinds of raw data that
we have and then naturally we also want
to process this data so we would have
various levels of pre-processing and
then analysis of this data as well so
the number of files for a given subject
is pretty high and this becomes
unmanageable when you're dealing with a
couple thousand patients so for us that
the brain signs the center hdf5
presented as the most optimal solution
and we also had rewritten our processing
pipeline from MATLAB to Python and it
was nice to know that hdf5 interface
very well with Python as well so what is
hdf5 well hg f stands for hierarchical
data format and this format it's a well
this HT of five is a data model library
and file format for storing and managing
your data and it can be basically
described as a file system within a file
I mean it's designed for flexible and
efficient storage and IO and high for
high volume and complex data so if
you're a person in you know various
fields of scientific research or others
if you deal with large numerical data
sets hdf5 is a useful format for you why
would you use HDFS well there are three
big picture reasons that I would
say and that would be processing sharing
and archiving of your data so if you're
processing if you're like me you maybe
are interested in a specific data set on
a couple of different subjects and you
want to access that data quickly and
easily or you want to hand that off to a
collaborator or a colleague quickly and
easily and sometimes this includes
different kinds of data that maybe
aren't of the same type then you only
want to have part of it well hdf5
supports large complex heterogeneous
data and data slicing so that's good for
processing for sharing many of us want
to share our data with collaborators
this becomes and so like sharing sharing
is caring we want to use something that
is pretty easy to use on multiple
platforms which HD or/5 is and it's also
self describing so you don't have to
have all of these extra documents on
your data you can just transfer the data
file itself and it's from an open format
which makes that good for particularly
scientific labs that don't have a lot of
funding and then for archiving I don't
know about all of you but I intend to
keep my data forever and I would like it
to be neatly stored and not stored kind
of like a packrat haphazardly hdf5
allows you to do this it has good
compression its self describing again
and also you might want to use HD or/5
because you can do it with Python and
that is reason enough all right
the structure of hdf5 there's basically
three things to think about groups
datasets and attributes so an hdf5 file
has two objects there's groups in
datasets and when you're thinking about
groups you're thinking about them as
Python dictionaries or if you're in sort
of the computer mindset it's basically
like folders or directories and if
you're thinking about datasets they act
very similar to numpy arrays and that
would be kind of like a file on within
one of your folders of directories on
your computer and an attribute is then
the metadata that can be on a group or
on a data set and that would be
something like a label on one of the
files or directories so this schematic
that is shown there and it's probably
easiest to keep in your head and it's
just showing
how groups can be within groups and data
sets can be within groups one thing to
note is that every hdf5 file has a root
directory so now we're going to jump in
to this ipython notebook and show you
some of the basic ways to get started
using h5 pi and hopefully this all it
does Oh
which it's not going to because that's
how the world works so the presentation
now works but now this isn't showing
sorry I said that we had it all together
it's showing that the displays are
mirrored so I'm not really sure here
yes all right so that's the this ipython
notebook is in that repository alright -
I'm gonna make this slightly smaller
write reminder again in hdf5 with a
couple things to think about data sets
groups and attributes data sets are like
dumped by race groups are like
dictionaries every object so those
objects in hdf5 file has a name and
they're arranged in POSIX style
hierarchy with slash separators it's
pretty easy to get going the only thing
that we're gonna rely on here is numpy
and I'll be using h5 PI I do know that
you can use hdf5 in PI tables but that
won't be covered today alright for
installs it's relatively simple you can
go to the h5 documentation in order to
figure out how to do that for your
particular install preference but you
can if you're using anaconda you can
just do comma install h5 5 right here
I'm just going to create a couple of
dumb PI arrays it's just for later use
these are of course very very small
arrays typically you would use hdf5 with
large numerical data sets but learning
and visualizing how the hierarchy works
with hdf5 is not so easy when you're
looking and visualizing large data sets
all right it's pretty easy to get a file
going this we're just gonna create a
file handle give this file a name data
and then hdf5 files work just like
standard python file objects and so they
have all the standard modes this is just
going to open up an empty hdf5 file for
us and then I will from there start
going through getting datasets groups
and attributes into here the goal with
this today would be if you haven't used
hdf5 you could take this notebook go
home and put all of your data in HD or/5
files
alright so from the file handle you can
see that there's a lot of different
methods that we have on the file object
and so one of the ones that we're going
to use a lot is create data set
and there'll be other file objects that
will be useful later on so to create a
data set on our file we can just give it
a data set name call it data we'll
assign the smaller right here and then
there's other keywords that you can use
within this function call in that
something like data type or shape or the
compression algorithms but I won't go
into those at this detail here so just
like a numpy array you will have this
data set is going to have a space and a
type and name and the other thing that
it will have that's in particular to
hdf5 would be it will be belonging to a
particular group in this case it's
belonging to the root group
alternatively this is another way that
you can assign a particular create a
data set in your hdf5 file so I'm just
gonna execute that again the same thing
but now you'll notice that in my parent
group sorry in my parent group here it
was one member before and now I know
that there are two members in my parent
group so another useful command-line
utilities h5 dump that can be will help
you visualize how you're structuring
your data so this is going to show
exactly what we just created so from the
group the root group we created a data
set called data and we assigned it the
the small array and then we also created
another data set called small data and
assigned a smaller array there so that's
pretty much how it it works to get a
data set set up another thing that is
useful as I described before that you
can do in hdf5 with the data sets is the
data slicing so just like you would use
a four number in this example here I
will have a short array that's just an
integer array and then just like in the
slicing I'm going to replace some of my
data and this works really well
particularly for those of us who are
dealing in the scientific community
where we maybe want to change some data
add on some data modify data in any form
using syntax that we're already very
familiar with all right the next thing
that we'll go on is on groups so groups
again are like
some dictionaries they all have names
the key values keys and then the values
would be either another group or a
dataset so again as I have mentioned
before when we create the file object it
is our route group but I can also then
label my route group or create groups on
top of that which is typically what
you're going to do so here we're just
going to create a group and we're going
to call it group one pretty simple and
then group op groups have methods just
like the file objects do and so from the
group you can create a group within that
group obviously subgroup here or we can
create groups implicitly so off the file
object I can use create group instead of
create dataset and I can list an entire
the path that I want to the group of
interest instead of making all of these
groups independently now that I've
created a couple of different groups on
my hdf5 file maybe I'm trying to
remember what groups I have on my root
directory and so the two groups I have a
Group one and group two then if I want
to look into group one and see what
kinds of what else I have underneath
that directory then I have a subgroup
you can also create a dataset within a
group that makes it instead of just like
you would on the function handle or the
file handle and so here we're gonna
create this I'd give it a name small and
assign some data now I know that this is
my path to the data and just be group on
my function or on my file it would be
Group one too small there's other ways
to create data sets in group these are
just a couple of different examples of
how you can create a dataset so for like
this first example here is something
that we would do often as you're
building up your razor you're doing
through your analysis and then you're
going to assign whatever data you create
into your file you can then come up with
you know the path name that you have or
the path to the groups into the data set
that you're interested in and then
assign your data all right so then now
we've created a bunch of different
groups
data sets within the same file and it's
kind of hard to visualize and think
about where that is so let's see where
we've come in H again h5 dump is
probably the easiest way to think about
what you've got in in your structure so
from the home group or the route group I
should say we've created two separate
groups on top of that Group 1 and group
2 within group 1 we have our small data
set again we see the data type in the
data space and then a list of our data
and we also have a subgroup within Group
1 from group 2 we've created a data set
that's just in group 2
but we've also created a subgroup and
then another couple of data sets within
those subgroups instead of looking let's
say at the h5 dump and you want to see
whether or not a particular group or
data set is indeed in your file you can
do it has containership testing and so
in this case yes indeed group 2 is on my
root directory or my root group and then
again you can use full path names for
containership testing as well all right
the next thing is attributes and
attributes are basically what makes hdf5
probably it makes it the self-describing
format but it also makes it the most
useful because instead of having all of
these extra documentation on my files or
on my datasets I can assign attributes
to the data set or to the group so these
are just small bits of information
there's a few following properties but
you basically it would be something like
this first example here where I've got
my small data set in in my file and I
need to let say that it has a sampling
rate and so I can assign this little
attribute to that data set in particular
and then I can assign a task type so
then once I've added in those attributes
I can see on my data set what kinds of
attributes I have it's pretty basic
we've got the sampling rate and the task
type are in there and what kinds of
values do I have this this item method
will on the attributes will let me know
what methods I assign you can also label
the dimensions of a data set which I
think is
one of the one of the more useful
features as well in in particularly in
science we have a lot of times we're
transposing different matrices and
knowing which dimensions correspond to
which pieces of information is useful so
that's an easy way to add those those
labels in there so now we can see again
after the h5 dump what we've
accomplished and that is so that'll be
down here so on my small array that I've
created under my group I know how
dimension labels that are right in there
and then I also have my attributes so my
sampling rate and my task type so what
else can you do with HDFS after you've
created the groups and datasets and
you've you've made your files that's but
you don't even have to go any further
than there that's pretty basic it will
keep your data organized compressed and
accessible but you can also do some
advanced things which I won't cover in a
lot of detail but I will briefly mention
them here so chunking is one of them so
typically if you have a data set that's
going to be laid out on disk and
traditional C order but you can also use
chunking as you're creating the data set
so that it would be divided up and
stored in a different way
this helps with many things in terms of
speed and efficiency that I will not
cover here but it's a pretty easy syntax
in terms of what you're trying to say to
your data set so if I'm creating a data
set just calling that data set here
chunked and then this is just creating a
random data set here and all I have to
do is assign the different chunks so in
this case the data would be read and
written in these blocks with 100 100
chain now if you are like me I don't
know how to decide on my chunk shape and
don't so then in you can use h5 high to
let it decide what kind of chunk shape
you would like and so you just can do
chunks equals true and then that saves
you some time trying to figure out what
size will work best for your data you
can also use different compression
algorithms within any hdf5
file compression is inherent to that but
you can decide on a different
compression algorithm should you want to
and there's several that are
and of course you can create your own
compression algorithm if you wanted you
can also do parallel hdf5 this is going
to be using the NPI for Python package
in which if you've used MPI it's pretty
easy to get started with that and it
requires a little bit more setup in
terms of getting started and getting
that compiled properly with the correct
libraries but it's definitely well worth
it not that difficult to get going if
you want other Python examples there on
the HDF group and they have several
Python examples along with many other
different code type examples all right
no we're going to pretend like we're
going to get back and it works okay so
now we that's just some basic ways about
how you can get started writing up some
code to get your data within an hdf5
file there's also some viewers that the
HDF group has made one of them is called
HD fu and the other is called HD f
compass and both of them are really
useful because you can it's kind of like
the hh5 dump that was the command-line
utility i was looking at but in this
case you can actually go in and plot
some of your data and interact with it
in a way that's useful and they are to
my knowledge expanding on those two
viewers to make it better for scientific
analysis of large-scale data so one of
the ways that I was going to try to
explain some of the it's a little bit
difficult for me to describe but we had
for our subjects so this is a small
schema of how we structure one subject
in our pre-processing scheme I would
have liked to have shown you more but
it's it's not so easy to visual
a large dataset so this is something
that we have done for our pre-processing
scheme if we have a subject that's gone
through the Meg and we have in that
session they will undergo a bunch of
different scan types and so for us it's
always eyes open for a minute and then
they do eyes closed for three minutes
and eyes open for a minute again plus we
have comments from the scan technicians
that are on that data and so the scan
the info here would be the scan
technicians documentation in terms of
was there a sensor out did the subject
sneeze was there movement
things of that nature that it's not
really structured but it's still good
information to have
along with the raw data and then we have
all of our time we have a time series
group because within the time series
group we have information about what
kinds of data is in there including the
headers of those and things like what
was the sampling rate in other bits of
information about how some of the
pre-processing was done you know from
the machine itself into the raw data
getting passed off to the data analysis
people so then again there's multiple
scans in there most of our people were
scanned in those particular ways but
there's other things like we might have
experimental designs where they're going
and doing you know several different
visualizing or playing games or things
like that and that gives us a lot of so
this is one part of our hdf5 file would
be all of the raw data then within that
same hdf5 file we can have our residuals
so we do time series analysis clearly
and we want to store the information
that we get on the pre-processing there
so we've all of our scan types and
groups again because within each scan
type we would have things like the time
series data at the time that it takes to
process for channel we would have things
like white noise residuals and how that
test has prevailed and given us values
in turn for passing and failing of the
test so this allows us to take all of
that bits of information and then go
into if we have this information now I
can go down to the correlations which
was our other group again the scan types
and then our different analysis
techniques down here along with some
attributes
so this was this is a structure that
we've used for our subs so this would be
one subject and we might have this would
be one subject one acquisition and a lot
of times we have you know thousands of
subjects that come in and get scanned on
multiple instances so this gives us a
way to be able to organize and access
our data easier I'd also point out that
our ability to structure files in this
hdf format hdf5 format is if you're not
working with people that know how to
code or read data they can easily follow
the you know directory the path syntax
and read these files straight off the
disk instead of trying to create some
other intermediary intermediate type
data set that you can hand off so a lot
of times if you have something in a
database people would have to either
write sequel queries well how do they
get that data out of there so this way
you can have simple ways for people just
to read the data right off desk so for
in the sciences and probably many other
places this is a definitely good format
for us it also say that even if you
don't have super large data sets
I really like the hdf5 format because I
can keep all of my processing within one
file so if you're like me and you go and
you want to do one model and then you
want to try a different model and then
you want to try a different model and
you want to try all these stats and
you're doing it on all these different
subjects instead of having all of these
different files around I have one file
that I can structure in a way that gives
me all the information that I need all
right and lastly I'll just go over some
take-home messages so again hdf5
is a file system within a file so groups
act like folders data sets act like
files and attributes act like labels on
the folders or files if you want to do
processing you want to work smarter not
harder as Eileen said in the previous
talk humans are lazy I think that this
is a good file format for lazy people it
can help make all of your data
accessible and it does support large
complex heterogeneous data and data
slicing and then of course the sharing
is
we want to work with our collaborators
well and this gives us a a format for
the data that is platform independent
self describing and of open format and
then if we want our data to live in
perpetuity hdf5 can help you do that
since it's compressed organized in self
describing so last I will get a hat tip
to my former BSC colleagues specifically
Shelley Shawn and then also to Andrew
Colette who's the leader of the lead
author of h5 pi and the HDF group about
people who do open source I can't do the
science that I need and hi how fast is
appending with this format because you
can imagine that if e series represents
a time series and you have multiple
groups within a file you might want to
capture all of your data for one day and
write it and then on the next day append
to all of the groups within the file so
it would be I mean you don't have to
read you don't have to read in your
original time series to append it so you
can just append on your original file
itself so it would be you know just as
fast as as depending on - you know any
numpy array it's not like going through
the directories makes it more
time-consuming if that makes sense yeah
what would you say about using hdf5 for
non numeric like integer and float up
things strings or objects like date
times and that kind of thing I've had
issues in the past she recommended is it
efficient that sort of thing I think
that there's probably other structures
that would mostly work well you can you
can use any data type you want within
hdf5 but if the main use of hdf5 in my
would be because you have large
numerical data and then on top of that
if you also have some integers and some
strings and different things then you
can also add that into the file format
but typically like I said if you're I
would imagine that there's other data
structures that would that would work
out better or other file formats and
yeah and the second question is how do
you compare using H 5pi to just the
stuff that pandas has to interact with
these file types well to interact with
the plot types I'm sorry I don't know
where you are yeah thank you um yeah cuz
I've done stuff with pandas and it seems
to work fine but I feel like I'm maybe
missing something that this package
possibly goes into be more depth um so
it's I mean it's it's storing and
managing data so it's not necessarily
analysis and I know pandas you can you
do time series in there I think it
depends and you could pull from an HD f5
file and put it on pandas dataframe then
interact with it that way and go back
and forth this would be yeah I mean for
like plotting they but if you're
worrying about the plotting that I would
keep separate those viewers are in a
work in progress I think that they can
help you look at things but I don't
actually use them at all so if you're
trying to interact with a time series I
would use other other means of
interacting with time series or storing
them that way this would be more
large-scale you know storage of your
data in a way that is compressed hey how
do you share data with your colleagues
do you have like one big master file
yeah how do you do that well if it
depends on the people so it no not in a
bad way but in a because I deal in human
data a lot of people don't a lot of
humans don't like me just giving away
information about their brain wherever
so typically we would have in the brain
science center I was before we have a
local storage server there and
we can just give people access through a
couple of different servers and they can
just read it directly from there and
using the hdf5 structure we would have a
couple of different wrappers so that
researchers could read directly from
those files so I would just give them
they would tell me what they want
I would query get a list file that just
gives the path to what they're looking
for so for example they say I want you
know all of the PTSD subjects you know
their first acquisition and I want their
correlations at you know 50 legs I can
create a list file that gives me all of
that very quickly because everything
would be structured the same for all of
the subjects and so I can just it's
basically you know writing a sequel
query but in a way that makes it a lot
easier for me to hand off a list file
for them to just read directly from disk
instead of creating copies of your data
over and over again or if you have
people that you know you don't want text
files of all of this data floating
around especially in science and me a
lot of a lot of times people don't have
this kind of memory on their local
systems that they're working with so
that's how we would do it
you can also that's I mean that's my
experience for sharing data yes you
mentioned compression I get this sense
that what we have here is on this
compression what about compassion in
memory because I've often have datasets
that are kind of too big to store store
in memory yet what I am doing on them
may not be particularly so complex so
for example you're doing some row by row
kind kind of transformation and you'd
want to store the rows that you're not
processing at the moment in a compressed
form in memory so I don't know about
compression and memory but I do know
that if you are just trying to work with
small bits of the data you can do that
so you can you just like an umpire you
can interact with you know if you only
want to interact with some rows or some
columns you can do that so one of the
things that we have is some of our
sensors fail or some of them don't
the modeling so when we get to did you
pass or didn't you pass I can go read in
that one didn't pass and I can go fill
in the values of you know that sensor
that didn't pass and only deal with that
not read in the whole dataset but in
terms of compression about that it might
be there but I'm not sure are you aware
of the blog post called moving away from
HD FL which it's somewhat famous and
came out this year but it says from
somewhat famous blog post with some
maybe some relevant criticisms of well
standardizing on this format are you
aware of the criticism I'm not aware of
the criticism I don't know of a better
file format for the kinds of data that I
deal with if there is one I'm more than
happy to discuss that in a lot of the
brain imaging that we do it's it's hard
for us to find I mean I also deal with a
lot of DICOM images and there's not a
good file format for that as well so I'd
be happy to learn more about it yeah
there are a number of points but I think
it it pays for people who are not really
familiar with usage there are some pros
and also some drawbacks oh there is some
risk of data corruption actually in
storing when for example your processes
crashes during the right so in that
sense it's less rubbish than the real
database system the special the specs
are very complex there's only really a
handful of people understand this it
ended there's only basically one
implementation around and the on this
format is actually not really frozen so
it might be subject to change so
somewhere maybe 10 or 5 20 years in the
future we might have to dig up a really
old version to read in your old version
hdf5 there's some of the criticism I'm
not saying I agree with all of them but
it's it it's useful to be aware of them
I think yes there's definite drawbacks
of using hdf5 like many other file
formats but at least to be organized if
not corrupt are questions I just had a
common I guess going to your common so
I'm a physicist and we have these things
called route files which they're quite
terrible to be honest I think that a one
so it's easy to complain about some of
the file formats that that exists in the
sciences and say oh why don't you go to
a database and I think that the there's
sort of a bigger reason which is just
that they I mean you need a certain
skill set and infrastructure to be able
to do database as well and also you have
a I mean you need to have these
solutions work for very long periods of
time I think typically much longer than
the current trend and technologies so I
think there are criticisms of the ways
the science is deal with data storage
but I think that it's a little bit more
difficult of a problem than then you're
indicating other questions well if no
that's it 10k murders again